Avengers end games relatively light body
count surprised a lot of fans shocked by
its predecessors carnage audiences brace
themselves for loss thankfully the
majority of Earth's heroes survived the
latest encounter with Thanos which
raises a new question why it doesn't
really seem like there's one right
answer endgame gave us a ton of heroes
and the filmmakers likely had different
reasons for keeping each survivor off
the chopping block here's why we think
the following Avengers survived endgame
everyone's favorite trash Panda came out
of Avengers endgame relatively unscathed
the easiest and most likely answer to
the question of rocket survival is
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 at Hasbro
has con 2017 guardians writer director
James Gunn told fans he had an origin
story for rocket that he planned to tell
he also warned Rockets life story would
likely be more horrible than it was in
the source material by March 2019 gun
was confirmed as directing the movie
using his screenplay so all things
considered it looks like we might be
learning more about Rockets past in
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 it would
be a pretty big bummer if we only got to
see that story after Thanos turned him
into a small rug unfortunately we didn't
see a lot of Akko yay an Avengers end
game she's in the final battle and
briefly speaks to Black Widow in the
beginning of the film beyond that she's
absent fortunately that also seemed to
increase her overall chances of
surviving through the movie's end an
infinity war two challahs last
interaction where the co ei is pretty
memorable huh this is no place today
in a way this moment is the answer to
her survival and endgame Okoye is part
of the MCU as a whole but she's
particularly important to the Black
Panther franchise if she were to ever
make the ultimate sacrifice it should be
in a black panther film not only that
but the aftermath of infinity war an
endgame leaves us with a lot of
questions about what Conda and we're
probably going to need Okoye way to get
some of those answers after all while
the people who were snapped were brought
back to life they still did disappear
which means the cholo was effectively
dead for five years the king of Wakanda
died without an heir and his sister
Cherie was dead as well what happened in
Wakanda during those five years who is
to chala going to find on the throne
Valkyrie was one of the most asked about
absences from Avengers infinity war
along with Korg and me we never see her
during dannis attack on the Asgardian
refugee ship and we didn't know if she
survived the purge Avengers endgame
finally gives us our answers along with
the rest of the surviving as guardians
Valkyrie settles in new Asgard with Thor
wallowing and depression alcohol and
fortnight's when Avengers endgame begins
someone has to take charge so the ones a
pathetic warrior we meet in thor
ragnarok
who once only cared about kidnapping
refugees and drinking becomes the de
facto queen of new Asgar her
contributions don't stop at the
administrative she also flies in on a
winged horse in the final battle against
Thanos Valkyrie star is rising
considering Marvel's statements about
increasing diversity in its films and
the fact that Valkyrie is a bisexual
woman of color
not to mention that regardless of her
sexuality or ethnicity she was a hugely
popular part of Ragnarok the character
has massive potential in the post
endgame MCU killing her off so early
would be a huge waste captain Marvel's
ticket sales broke many records and
continued to break more and there's
definitely going to be a sequel so the
idea of killing her off in Avengers
endgame would have been pretty nuts
beyond Captain Marvel's own franchise
Avengers endgame opens an opportunity
for the hero to perform another role
leader
endgame left a huge void in the Avengers
leadership Captain America is now
eligible to join AARP and Black Widow
and Ironman
our dead if the Avengers are going to
move forward they'll need a new leader
and those are shoes that Carol Danvers
has build in the comics we're pretty
certain the big screen version could do
the same
Thor was another hero a lot of fans
guest was going to get the axe
his entire family is dead his hammer got
shattered his people are practically
extinct and his home exploded we can
rebuild this place it will become a
haven for all peoples and aliens of the
universe why wouldn't the Thunder God
make another suicide run at Thanos what
does he have to live for well for one
thing better movies Tyco white tee tees
thor ragnarok revived the whole thor
franchise before that Chris Hemsworth
had apparently grown bored with the
character but now the sky's the limit
which is exactly where Thor is headed he
hops aboard the benatar toward the end
of endgame to join the guardians of the
galaxy so does this mean we should
expect Thor to be part of guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 or is what he said to
Bal curry true are the guardians just
giving him a ride maybe to another white
TT directed Thor film or is this the
last time we should expect to see the
Odinson outside the comics we don't know
and Hemsworth says he doesn't either
regardless the potential is there and
that's enough to keep him alive cool
cool so cool rody was pretty much right
at the top of the list of characters
most people expected to die in endgame
he's a sidekick he had a shot at a solo
film that never materialized his
superhero name is one of the least
family-friendly titles you could think
of war machine was a little too
aggressive alright this sends a better
message and to top it all off
Thanos did kill him in the comics and
not that long ago during an ill-fated
assault on the mad Titan in 2016 civil
war two panels put his fist through war
machines chest if you're not a comics
reader but you saw endgame with friends
who are Marvel comic fans you can bet
they were worried when Thanos headed for
Morag while rody and nebula were there
trying to get the Power Stone all of
that is precisely why rody survives
endgame during the span of the four
films they've directed for Marvel
Studios Joe and Anthony Russo have
proven their mastery at going against
expectation they're not going to kill
Rhodey when everyone is
again they're going to kill rody
considering what we've seen from them
they probably put roadie on the more AG
team because they knew fans would be
seen skulls as soon as Thanos set course
for the rock nebula survival was one of
the most surprising outcomes of endgame
she has a hacked first think later
attitude that never serves her well
against her powerful father she's
impulsive damaged and suffers a well of
endless rage I thought you were the
biggest sadist in the galaxy in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 she plies
a spaceship into a cavern while trying
to kill Gamora and keeps going even
after the wings break off if there's one
thing the Hulk teaches us in the opening
scene of infinity war it's that your
head better pack as much of a punch as
your fist if you're going after Thanos
all in all nebula seems doomed from the
start but she survives and gain at least
the nebula of the present survives her
past self gets a hole in her chest one
of the reasons nebula survives is likely
the same as Rhodey the expectation of
death was high so the Russo brothers
went in the opposite direction but
probably the biggest reason is her
potential and guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 on one hand if nebula were to die
in endgame then mantis would be the only
woman left on the team since the
whereabouts of 2014 Gamora are unknown
on the other end game changes nebula
dramatically she spent years with the
Avengers and with rocket she's played
paper football with Tony Stark the
nebula we meet in volume 3 will be a
very different cyborg than the one we're
used to marvel's green Goliath was
expected to be headed to the gladiator
arena in the sky after the story broke
that Mark Ruffalo filmed five different
endings to Avengers end game once the
much more articulate version of the Hulk
slid on the new Infinity Gauntlet it's
likely fans were worried this was going
to be the end for the Jade giant but it
wasn't meant to be
he gets a nasty burn on his arm and the
last time we see him he's wearing a
sling but Bruce Banner gets to live to
see the aftermath of endgame
one possible reason for Hulk's continued
existence might be found in the most
recent rumor about Disney plusses MCU
original series while nothing's been
confirmed shortly before end games
release a report circulated that a Hulk
and she
series was in development for the
upcoming streaming service in the comics
it's Bruce banners cousin who becomes
she-hulk
after he's forced to save her life with
a blood transfusion whether those
details will remain the same or if the
series is actually in developments
remains a mystery but it could prove to
be the reason the MCU Hulk survived
saving half the people in the universe
things look really bad for cap and
endgame once Thanos start shredding his
shield with that huge double sword it
seems like he's finally going to get to
visit Peggy Carter and Howling Commandos
in the USO show in the sky now Chris
Evans his contract is up and if there's
an unwritten code of comic-book law
somewhere one of those rules is that
when caps shield breaks all bets are off
thankfully for cap Peggy and all of us
Steve is still with us though he's a bit
older once the big final battle is over
cap uses his assignment to return the
Infinity stones to their rightful places
in the timeline to also return to the
love of his life
Peggy an aged Steve Rogers hands off his
shield to Sam Wilson and so ends the
saga of the MCU s original Captain
America it's almost unthinkable to end
caps journey any other way to simply
kill him even in some glorious heroic
manner isn't enough just as Tony Stark
deserves his rest Steve Rogers deserves
the chance to live a full life and
finally get that dance with Peggy figure
that way
right partner and with two other
founding MCU Avengers dying in endgame
we needed at least one to get a happier
ending
the only thing Hawkeye does better than
shoot arrows is full audiences about
who's going to die in a 2016 interview
Aaron taylor-johnson who played
Quicksilver in Avengers age of Ultron
said that one of the reasons his
character dies saving Hawkeye is that
director Joss Whedon was playing with
the widespread belief that hawkeye would
die in the sequel director's Joe and
Anthony Russo seemed to use a similar
strategy for Avengers end game Hawkeye
and Black Widow are tasked with getting
the soul stone
meaning one of them must sacrifice
themselves for it Hawkeye seems the
perfect choice with his despair about
the horrific things he's done since the
purge he barely seems like a candidate
for happy ending instead it's Black
Widow who dies for stone Hawkeye also
survives because he has more work to do
in early April 2019 Variety reported
that a series featuring Hawkeye was in
development for the upcoming Disney Plus
streaming service that's likely not the
biggest reason though after all Black
Widow has an upcoming film and neither
vision nor Loki receive endgame
resurrections despite similar upcoming
Disney Plus series perhaps the chief
reason Hawkeye survives is his family
for his wife and children to be
resurrected at the end without Clint to
welcome them would be too tragic a note
for a story already rife with grief
spider-man's death scene and Avengers
infinity war was one of the most
gut-wrenching in a sequence filled with
death scenes it's surprising no one he
returns after the Hulk uses the Infinity
stones and reversed thanasis purge he's
a major player in the final battle
against Thanos and his forces being one
of the Avengers to secure the Infinity
Gauntlet from the mad Titan until he
inevitably gets it back but loses all
the same of course the fact that we all
saw the spider-man far from home trailer
months before the release of endgame was
a big hint that Peter would not only
come back but survive the bill to anyone
who wasn't sure the perched heroes of
infinity war would return to challahs
death was one that should have convinced
them with black panther proving to be
one of Marvel Studios most successful
films the first
for Euro film to be nominated for a Best
Picture Oscar and writer director Ryan
Coogler already working on a sequel it
was obvious the king of Wakanda couldn't
stay dead forever which isn't to say his
death an infinity war is meaningless or
without stakes in spite of his
resurrection
by the time Black Panther 2 hits the
screen while Conda will have gone at
least five years without its king not
only that but T'Challa is lost at a
critical time in the nation's history
when at two challahs direction it moves
away from isolationism and reveals its
technological superiority to the world
we don't know who if anyone was on the
throne in two challahs absence may be
Raimondo maybe in Baku the nation he
returns to in black panther 2 will
likely be very different from the one he
died fighting for an infinity war people
were not too happy with dr. strange
after Avengers infinity war in spite of
strange telling Tony that surrendering
the time stone to Thanos was the only
way once he gets back to earth
stark accuses strange of quotes giving
away the stone Bruce Banner doesn't seem
very happy with strange either when he
tells the ancient one about what he did
of course in the end it turns out that
the one timeline in which Thanos loses
needs Tony Stark alive the fact remains
that strange did give up the eye of
Okimoto which means the forces of Conor
Tosh have lost their greatest weapon
Thanos destroys all of the Infinity
stones before Thor kills him and even
after some time travel high jinks that
return all the stones from the past
to the respective times and places so
that nothing is disrupted the time stone
will still be destroyed the relic that
allowed stranged outwit Dormammu is gone
and kamar Taj needs Doctor Strange more
than ever none of that would matter if
there were going to be any more Doctor
Strange belts but on that score we don't
need to worry
in December 2018 The Hollywood Reporter
broke the news that Doctor Strange
director scott derrickson was poised to
return for the sequel and Cumberbatch
seems just as eager to return to his
sanctum the end of endgame proves to be
a new beginning for Sam Wilson while the
Avengers expect Captain America to
return from his time John s planned
instead an aged Steve Rogers appears
wearing a wedding ring and waiting for
Falcons so he can pass on a heavy
to the much younger hero Sam Wilson is
poised to be the new Captain America as
he was for a time in the comics he seems
reluctant to accept the shield at first
when Steve asks how the shield feels Sam
says like it's someone else's once Steve
responds it isn't Sam takes a long deep
breath and thanks his old partner
on one hand Falcons death would be more
problematic considering he and Bucky are
about to share a miniseries on Disney
plus more importantly Falcon can't die
because the legacy of Captain America
needs to live on in younger hands and
for many reasons it couldn't be Bucky
forget Black Widow that guy's got way
too much red in his Ledger before scene
endgame you could hardly blame anyone
for putting Bucky in their Avengers end
game death fool he isn't exactly the
most popular superhero and considering
the blood-soaked past he wrestles with
it's easy to imagine the former Hydra
assassin would see death as a welcome
respite the winter soldiers most
predictable role post endgame would have
been is the new Captain America
considering Chris Evans is MCU exit and
the fact that Bucky took up the mantle
of Captain America for time in the
comics but we now know that honor went
to Sam Wilson the Falcons going to need
some guidance in his new role at as much
as he and Bucky haven't gotten along in
the past
Bucky's probably the best choice for
Sam's partner speaking with
Entertainment Weekly the Russo brothers
confirmed that bucking knew about caps
plan to go back in time and get back the
life he lost when he plunged into the
ice considering Bucky seems unsurprised
by cap handing the shield over to Sam it
seems likely the two also discussed what
needed to happen we're probably going to
see what that help looks like in the
upcoming Disney Plus Falcon Winter
Soldier Series I've done that earlier I
hate you check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about Avengers and gamer coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]